ein finsteres relikt eines
verbrecherischen regimes mit was gibt
schlafsäle so was die klassenzimmer
werkstätten sehr merkwürdig
geister straßen einer versunkenen
piraten stadt in der karibik
die hafen mauern bröckeln ins meer und
das ganze areal ist dem verfall
preisgegeben
eine berüchtigte plantage im süden der
usa
man hat so eine dunkle vorahnung dass
sie etwas passiert sein muss aber was
und ein unterirdischer megabau der half
einen krieg zu gewinnen
willst du nicht mal in seinen kühnsten
träumen kommt man darauf was sich hinter
diesen türen verbirgt
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
hier werden ihre geheimnisse gelüftet
[Musik]
inmitten des adriatischen meeres unweit
der kroatischen küste liegt eine insel
die nur selten besucht wird
eine mondlandschaft nur aufgetürmte
steinhaufen alles ist grau und weiß
es ist kalt es gibt kaum bäume die
schatten bieten oder den wind brechen
diese insel ist einfach nur abweisen sie
ist karl
du siehst verbrannt und sie ist tot
[Musik]
an einem hang sind verschiedene treppen
und ruinen
eigentlich nur noch fundamente
bei genauerem hinsehen sind da einige
düstere überbleibsel
der ort ist umringt von maschinengewehr
nestern und stacheldraht retten was
alles noch viel seltsamer macht
welchen düsteren zweck diente dieser ort
auf dieser insel sollten wille und stolz
gebrochen werden
menschlich
[Musik]
doch was steckt hinter dieser morbiden
anlage wer hat hier gelebt wurde man
hier beschützt oder eingesperrt
[Musik]
die unwirtliche felseninsel heißt goli
otok
[Musik]
heimatforscher darko baljak untersucht
die anlage seit jahren und kennt ihre
geheimnisse
auf dieser insel herrschten paranoia und
gewalt
je intensiver man die insel erforscht
desto mehr fragezeichen wirft sie auf
es schaut man sich die anlage genauer an
stößt man auf schlafräume und ein
auditorium
es war schwer zu sagen was das ist
auf den ersten blick scheint es total
unlogisch zu einer halb industrielle
anlage auf einer insel mitten im meer zu
bauen
die isolierte lage goliath ochs ist
einer der schlüssel zur nutzung dieses
ortes
was auch immer hier draußen mit den
menschen geschah es blieb auf der insel
wenn man sich die bunker ansieht ist
klar dass dieser ort so angelegt wurde
dass er überwacht und verteidigt werden
konnte
aber es ist schleierhaft warum gerade
hier etwas überwacht werden musste
tatsächlich war goli otok ein brutales
gefängnis auch bekannt als das alcatraz
kroatiens
[Applaus]
wenn wir die ersten gefangenen trafen
hier am 9 juli 1949 ein
über die jahre kamen rund 12.000
strafgefangene an diesen ort und alles
was man hier sieht wurde von umgebaut
aber warum musste dieses gefängnis
mitten im meer auf dieser kargen insel
errichtet und vor den augen der welt
versteckt werden
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg gehört goli
otok zum kommunistisch regierten
jugoslawien einem damals engen
verbündeten moskaus
doch 1948 bricht der jugoslawische
ministerpräsident josip tito mit stalin
und den kurs der sowjet kommunisten
[Musik]
es kommt zu protesten gegen diesen anti
sowjet kurs doch tieto hat von moskau
gelernt er macht mit seinen kritikern
kurzen prozess
do you want to be good to wir jeden der
loyal zu stalin steht verschwinden
lassen
titus macht hunger macht auch vor seinen
eigenen leuten nicht halt er lässt sie
zu tausenden verhaften und schickt sie
als politische gefangene ins gefängnis
nach goli otok
titus version eines gulags
[Musik]
jürgens die gebäude sind eine
reminiszenz an die paranoia eines
regimes das seinem eigenen volk nicht
dort
sie muss mir jahrelang unter schlimmsten
bedingungen leben
sie kauerten auf dieser kalkstein insel
in ihren behausungen und mussten sich zu
tode schuften
das gefängnis regime lässt die häftlinge
ein großes netzwerk vom tunnel graben
und sie müssen die mauern bauen hinter
denen sie eingesperrt sind
[Musik]
auf der insel gibt es über 100 bunker
viele wurden gebaut um die häftlinge an
einer flucht zu hindern
[Musik]
jene die das pech haben hierzulande
müssen titus unbarmherzige um erziehungs
maschinerie durchlaufen und die arbeitet
mit teuflischer präzision
diese anlage war ein brutaler hinsicht
sehr erfolgreich darin den menschen leid
und schmerz zuzufügen
jugoslawiens berüchtigte geheimpolizei
stellt sicher dass das um
erziehungssystem reibungslos
funktioniert und für die jugoslawische
bevölkerung wird goli otok zum
einschüchternden schreckgespenst
die psychologischen folgen müssen
traumatisierend gewesen sein mann
verschwand einfach und wusste nicht mal
welche verbrechen mann beschuldigt wurde
alles ging so schnell und spurlos das
nicht mal freunde und familie wussten wo
man war
keinem der insassen wurde jeder prozess
gemacht sie wurden einfach verhaftet
mitgenommen und hierher geschickt
oftmals reicht ein kleinster vorwand wie
offen über andere kommunistische länder
zu sprechen manchmal machten die leute
ihren persönlichen unmut luft und
schwersten andere wegen politischer
verbrechen an die sie nie begangen
hatten weil sie wollten dass sie nach
goli otok kommen im gefängnis gibt es
ein einzigartiges system der
disziplinierung
obwohl es gefängnispersonal gibt das für
die ordnung im gulag zuständig ist
obliegt deren durchsetzung anderem
für die gefängnis disziplin wurde von
den insassen selbst gesorgt
wenn neuer häftlinge ankamen wurden
ältere insassen gezwungen diese aus zu
peitschen
wer die tortur überlebt steigt nicht
selten zum baracken aufseher auf um dann
sein eigenes terrorregime durchzusetzen
der baracken aufseher war herr über
leben und tod er konnte jedem insassen
befehlen einen anderen
zusammenzuschlagen
diese beispiellose brutalität erzeugte
so eine art gefängnis hierarchie die
insassen wurden ermutigt sich
gegenseitig zu demütigen sich zu
denunzieren und zusammenzuschlagen
[Musik]
jeder war gewalttätig und niemand fühlte
sich sicher
aber als ungefähr 600 menschen starben
auf der insel abertausende die zurück
aufs festland gekommen sind waren
gebrochen und umerzogen wurden und die
blieben stumm
[Musik]
angst wieder angeschwärzt und nach goli
otok zurückgeschickt zu werden diese
angst verfolgte jugoslawen bis 1989 als
der fall der berliner mauer das ende des
kommunismus einläutet
täters kulac wird aufgegeben
heute sind die ruinen von goli otok eine
düstere erinnerung an die
unmenschlichkeit von titus totalitären
regime
[Musik]
im westen gab es viele die abwiegelte
die meinten titels diktatur sei nicht so
schlimm wie die anderer kommunistische
regierung
dass sie nicht auf brutalität und
straflagern basiert
aber das stimmt natürlich nicht
[Musik]
in den sümpfen louisianas liegt eine
weitläufige siedlung mit einer traurigen
vergangenheit
[Musik]
das ist wie aus einer anderen welt
den merkwürdigen tiere wie schlangen die
durchs gras schlängeln die krokodile
nicht besonders gemütlich
die überreste von überwachsenen
backstein fundamenten aus der landschaft
hervor
[Musik]
es gibt aber auch einfach holzhäuser
das sind wirklich einfachste behausungen
kleine schuppen die hastig zusammen
gezimmerte sind und heute kaum noch
stehen
doch die gebäude und die rostigen
gerätschaften im sumpf louisianas
verraten was auf dieser anlage einst
passiert ist
des ankaufs der entfernung sieht man so
etwas wie einen kran oder eine
industrielle anlage und anderes schweres
gerät
alles total verfallen
es scheint sich um eine
landwirtschaftliche einrichtung zu
handeln aber wofür genau
es beschleicht einen die dunkle
vorahnung dass hier etwas passiert sein
muss aber was genau
wer sind die arbeiter die hier unter
erbärmlichen bedingungen werden mussten
und wie waren ihre leben mit der
zerrissenen geschichte amerikas
verflochten
[Musik]
die anlage wird viele fragen auf ein
kleiner zug und rostige industrie
fragmente deuten darauf hin dass dieser
ort industriell genutzt worden ist
die hütten und eine verlassene schule
wiederum zeugen von vergangenem
gemeinschaftsleben
[Musik]
heimatforscher policy erforscht die
anlage seit jahren
ich lebe hier seit
1977 und habe das gelände quasi
wiederentdeckt und ich war total
verblüfft über die vielen gebäude das
war wie eine zeitkapsel
die geschichte fängt mit einem produkt
an das auf der ganzen welt genutzt wird
zucker
das hier ist eine zucker plantage eine
landwirtschaftliche nutzung die im
neunzehnten jahrhundert und davor in den
usa sehr verbreitet war
wirtschaft basiert zum großen teil auf
zucker andauerten damit ließ sich gutes
geld verdienen
doch das ist nicht irgendeine
zuckerrohrplantagen
dies ist laurel valley damals eine der
größten konnten nordamerikas
[Musik]
der in den 1800 30er jahren ließ sich
eine gewisse familie tucker hier nieder
und baute die plantage auf
doch für ihr ehrgeiziges projekt
brauchen sie arbeiter
[Musik]
die packers kommen mit einigen dutzend
sklaven an nach 20 jahren sind es schon
fast 170 sklaven
sie sind eine sehr große sklavenhalter
familie
die zuckerproduktion war ein beinhartes
geschäft und verlangte den arbeitern
alles ab
das herzstück der zuckerproduktion ist
die mühle
die alte mühle wurde in den 1800 40er
jahren gebaut die ziegelsteine dafür
wurden vor ort von den sklaven gemacht
und dann aufgemauert
insgesamt 366 1000 steine aus sklaven
arbeit
die mühle arbeitete rund um die uhr die
stand nur still wenn etwas kaputt war
ein zug kam von hier unten mit
güterwaggons und hielt unter dem kran
der krank dann die ernte und lud sie in
einen trog wo sie gewaschen wurde
dann wurde sie in die mühle gebracht
gebrochen und daraus der zucker gewonnen
die arbeit ist hart
der arbeitstag in laurel wehre begann um
7 30 und endete gegen acht uhr abends
häufig wurden die felder nachts
umgepflügt die arbeitsbedingungen waren
sehr hart und die lebenserwartung der
arbeiter lag bei rund 25 jahren
[Musik]
es ist das ist klar wenn arbeit unter
sehr schlechten bedingungen die sümpfe
sind voller mythen es gibt malaria die
sonne knallt von oben sklaven hatten es
nirgendwo leicht aber hier war es
besonders schlimm
die jüngsten unter den arbeitern waren
so um die acht neun oder zehn
kinder unter solche menschenverachtenden
bedingungen ins leben zu setzen kommt
für viele nicht in frage
es gibt berichte über frauen die ihre
kinder getötet haben um sie vor dass
sklaverei zu bewahren
die verlassenen hütte von
zeugen von der brutalität des alltags
stellen sie sich vor hier im sumpf in
einer dieser primitiven hütten zu leben
aus der krone fliegengitter um die
mücken fernzuhalten
man ist zu fünft in einem zimmer alles
ist primitiv und unwirtlich
doch schon bald sollte eine reihe
gewaltsamer ereignisse über amerika
hinweg schwappen und auch nicht vor den
packers halt machen
für die menschen in den südstaaten war
die sklaverei eine tragende säule ihrer
wirtschaft obwohl es
mehrfachuntersuchungen gab die belegen
dass sklaverei an sich ineffizient ist
trotzdem war die sklaverei teil der
südstaaten kultur
das gilt vor allem für die packers
zwei jahre nach ausbruch des
bürgerkriegs verlässt kaka 1863 long
valley und schließt sich der
konfigurierten armee an
[Musik]
für einen mann wie caleb kaka der selbst
viele sklaven hielt kommt die idee von
der aufhebung der sklaverei einem
offenbarungseid gleich
der siebte unionisten über die
konföderierten hat katastrophale folgen
für packers plantage
[Musik]
die unionisten fordern wiedergutmachung
und lassen laut aufzeichnung die
plantage plündern
das macht es den plantagen besitzern zu
kriegsende noch schwerer
schließlich geben die packers ihre
plantage auf die sklaven aus long valley
sind frei
doch ihre hoffnung auf ein besseres
leben sollte sich nicht erfüllen
die zeit nach dem bürgerkrieg ist
wirklich herzzerreißend
denn es bot sich durchaus die
gelegenheit diesen landarbeiter sklaven
zu ihrem recht zu verhelfen
sie wenden sich auf dem weg zu einer
gerechteren gesellschaft
aber die periode des neuaufbaus währte
nur kurz
rassenhass und niedrige löhne verhindern
dass sich die zustände in laurel valley
grundlegend ändern der 1887 groß
angelegte streik wird von einer rein
weißen miliz blutig niedergeschlagen
sie töteten nicht nur die streitenden
sondern massakrierten am ende auch
schwarze zivilisten in der stadt
historiker wissen bis heute nicht wie
viele schwarze genau dabei umkamen aber
es waren sicher dutzende die ermordet
und abgeschlachtet wurden
die streikenden haben keine wahl sie
kehren an ihre arbeitsplätze in den
zuckerrohrfeldern zurück und die arbeit
in der plantage läuft wieder an ein
zuckerbrot zwischen 1890 und 1924 führt
zum bau neuer hütten und anlagen
es gab riesige kräne um den zucker zu
verladen es gab kilometerlange
eisenbahnschienen tonnenweise material
wurde bewegt und es wurde viel in die
infrastruktur investiert um alles am
laufen zu halten
doch die weltwirtschaftskrise in den
1930 er bedeutet das ende der
zuckerindustrie in großem stil in süd
louisiana
die hütten leeren sich und die zur mühle
stellt den betrieb für immer ein
zeugnisse dieser unrühmlichen geschichte
finden sich noch heute auch zuckerrohr
wird noch angebaut doch die unterkünfte
sind verwaist
diese anlage ist ein fenster in unserer
vergangenheit und die der ganzen welt
und so tragisch diese geschichte auch
ist so wichtig ist es dass sie gehört
und weitererzählt wird
[Musik]
auf einer abgelegenen unsere in den
schottischen highlands wacht eine reihe
von gebäuden still über das meer
[Musik]
die landschaftliche schönheit dort oben
auf den klippen ist atemberaubend
aber wenn man auf den boden schaut sieht
man betonfundamente der mensch war hier
er hat dinge geschaffen und sie wieder
zerstört
und noch mehr ist hier zu finden
[Musik]
versteckt im grünen ist ein
geheimnisvolles tor in die vergangenheit
wenn man nicht gezielt danach sucht wird
man kaum zufällig darüber stolpern
man stößt auf große stahltüren und sie
scheinen tatsächlich direkt in den berg
hinein zu führen
nicht mal in seinen wildesten träumen
käme man darauf was dahinter liegt
was immer es ist es ist nicht auf
örtlichen karten verzeichnet
noch eindrucksvoller als dieser komplex
ist das was man nicht davon sieht
geheimhaltung war das a und o bei dieser
operation
die dimensionen der anlage sind enorm
erst wenn man ein geräusch macht nimmt
man die ausmaße dieses orts war
die sechs kathedralen gegen den
schottischen bergen begraben sind
doch warum wurde diese riesige anlage
unter der erde erbaut und welche
verbindung hat sie zu den ruinen hoch
oben auf den felsen
die antwort findet sich vier kilometer
von ihr in waddan wenn man die dortigen
metallkonstruktionen unter die lupe
nimmt
sie sehen aus wie ein industriekomplex
die ganze anlage ist extrem wichtig
letztlich sieht man diese massiven
rundenpause so weit das auge reicht
um reihe dieser rostigen runden kuppeln
erstreckt sich bis zum horizont
der militär archäologe allen für patrick
kennt diese anlage wie seine
westentasche
es sei das ganze areal ist sehr
eindrucksvoll die ingenieursarbeit die
hier drin stellt ist exzellent
die seltsamen metall silos stammen aus
dem frühen 20 jahrhundert
sie wurden 1913 gebaut und stehen noch
heute
da wurde seit mehr als 25 jahren nicht
saniert wurden sind in einem erstaunlich
guten zustand
[Musik]
im innern dieser runden kuppeln ist es
kohlrabenschwarz doch da ist diese fast
pudrige weiße substanz echt unheimlich
das weiße pulver in den leeren tanks ist
organischer herkunft
es stammt von dem schwarzen gold des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
[Musik]
der größte dieser enormen stahltanks ist
fast 37 meter hoch und 14 meter im
durchmesser
in das gesamte tanklager passen
hunderttausende tonnen öl hinein
insgesamt wurden 44 öltanks gebaut von
denen jeder 5000 tonnen heizöl fassen
konnte
[Musik]
doch was ist mit all dem öl geschehen
und welche verbindung gibt es zu den
küsten ruinen und den dunklen gängen
unter der erde
[Musik]
im ersten weltkrieg war dies ein
zentraler logistik punkt für die
britische marine
für die navy war treibstoff immens
wichtig genauso wichtig wie munition
oder geschütze ein
treibstoff keine flotte
in war gordon liegt an der croma tiefe
einem meeresarm an der schottischen
nordseeküste
im vergoldeten begonnen war strategisch
sehr bedeutsam denn im schutze der
dunkelheit konnten die schiffe dort
auftanken und wieder verschwinden
in vergolden ist eine wichtige basis im
ersten weltkrieg und hilft derweil navy
dabei den sie krieg gegen das deutsche
kaiserreich zu gewinnen aber die klippen
routinen östlich von val gordon deuten
darauf hin dass das tanklager einst in
schwierigkeiten geriet dies sind die
überbleibsel der küsten batterie von
marc sutter
1913 gebaut werden sie noch zu beginn
des zweiten weltkriegs nachgerüstet um
das wertvolle öl der navy abermals zu
verteidigen
all die anstrengungen wurden unternommen
um die anlage vor luftangriffen zu
schützen die die rollen navy bedrohten
als die deutschen 1941 norwegen besetzen
haben sie plötzlich eine küste in
schlagdistanz zu schottland
im februar 1941 fliegt eine junkers 88
einen einzel angriff auf ihn war gordon
und wirft 215 bomben ab
dank 13 wurde zerstört und das öl lief
auf eine angrenzende bahnlinie und ins
meer
13 wurde nicht wieder aufgebaut man
sieht die lücke im tanklager also immer
noch
der angriff hat die briten nicht
überrascht vier jahre lang bauen sie an
einer lösung um sogar noch mehr
treibstoff in der nähe zu lagern aber wo
genau
wenn man nicht weiß wo der eingang ist
wusste man nicht mal dass es diesen ort
überhaupt gibt
risotto am berghang gibt es eine tür aus
unglaublich dickem stahl steel fest im
beton verankert ist
geheimnis eines inter dieser
unscheinbaren türen wer kann befindet
sich ein herausragendes beispiel der
ingenieurskunst
dies ist einer von zwei tunneln der in
dieser abgelegenen heilen tögel 150
meter oberhalb von in borden hineinführt
je tiefer man in den komplex vorstößt
dass du mehr erschließt sich seine größe
der eingangs tunnel ist mehr als 220
meter lang
ein paar mitarbeiter scheint der tunnel
abrupt zu ende
sobald man das ende des tunnels erreicht
hat erschließt sich ein weiterer weg
allerdings durch einen deutlich längeren
die arbeiter mussten sich flach auf ein
rollbrett leben und wurden dann durch
eine röhre geschubst
von dort geht es in einen riesigen
hohlraum
des der raum über meer ist riesig
[Musik]
groß als seine
mittelalterliche kathedrale
die nackten ausmaße sind 238 meter lange
und neun meter breit und 15 meter hoch
der bau ist absolut eindrucksvoll
[Musik]
dies ist nur einer von insgesamt sechs
textes unterirdischen tanklagers von
incheon dauern das erste ist 1941
fertiggestellt worden und hat ein
fassungsvermögen von mehr als 21
millionen liter mehr als 120 meter unter
der erde kann selbst die stärkste
deutsche bombe den ölreserven nichts
anhaben durch ein system von
rohrleitungen wird das öl nach in
verdorben gepumpt
das öl fließt durch gut sechs kilometer
lange leitungen von den tanks bis zum
marinebasis
600 arbeiter hatten diese gigantischen
tunnel gebaut
crowe eine viertelmillion kubik mit der
sandstein wurde aus der anlage
herausgebracht
schon bald sollte dieses meisterwerk der
baukunst eine wichtige rolle in der
größten see invasion der geschichte
spielen
im zweiten weltkrieg versorgt diese
anlage die flotte über einen langen
zeitraum ohne
basen wie diese gäbe es die räume die
nicht
1944 haben viele der schiffe die für die
dj landungen an die strände der
normandie gefahren sind viel in
vergolden aufgetankt die anlage war ein
wichtiger teil der flotten infrastruktur
und die anlage spielt eine entscheidende
rolle bei den finalen sieg der
alliierten im zweiten weltkrieg
auch nach dem krieg ist das öllager von
engine down von großer strategischer
bedeutung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese anlage war während des kalten
krieges ein wichtiges und sicheres
treibstofflager für die navy und von
großer logistischer bedeutung
pläne die anlage für die nato zu
erweitern aber diese pläne wurden
fallengelassen und seit 2002 ist die
anlage offiziell geschlossen
was für etwas das 1941 gebaut wurde ist
das eine unglaublich lange reise und
eine enorme lebensdauer
[Musik]
bis zum heutigen tage sind die öllager
von engine bauen in vielerlei hinsicht
rekordverdächtig
so produziert die anlage den längsten
nachhall der jemals aufgezeichnet wurde
es dauerte 117 sekunden ist das echo
sich langsam auflöste und dem nichts
verschwand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im süden jamaikas am eingang zum hafen
von kingston befindet sich ein wind
umtost es dorf mit einer turbulenten
vergangenheit
ist diese langgestreckte halbinsel die
ins meer ragt und man sieht am wuchs der
bäume wie sehr sie dem wind ausgesetzt
ist
[Musik]
an der küste steht ein längliches
gebäude der putz fällt von den wänden
und die elemente haben ihnen sichtbar
zugesetzt
vereinzelte hinweise lassen auf eine
militärische nutzung schließen
man sieht dicke mauern und einen turm
mit bogen denn es gibt einen großen hof
mit seltsamen holz strukturen im boden
wenn man um die ecke biegt sind
verschiedene zum teil heruntergekommene
kanonen einige verrosten andere sehen so
aus als könnten sie gleich los feuern
irgendetwas muss hier aus dem ruder
gelaufen sein
[Musik]
passiert ein gebäude ist komplett zu
einer seite gekippt aber ansonsten
bestens in schuss was kann ein ganzes
haus einfach umkippen
die hafenmauer bröckelt ins meer und der
ganze ort ist gespenstisch tätige bayer
scheinen etwas zu verbergen vielleicht
bewahrt auch das meer das düstere
geheimnis dieses ortes
doch wie ist es dazu gekommen dass diese
ruinen im wasser verschwunden sind
welches geheimnis verbirgt diese
siedlung
ein seltsam deplatziert es backstein vor
thront über dem hafen und lässt erahnen
dass dies nicht immer ein einer
fischerhafen war
[Musik]
dies ist eine militärische anlage doch
aus welcher zeit sie stammt und was sie
beschützt wird nicht sofort klar
was ist an der japanischen küste so
wertvoll dass es durch diese festung
beschützt werden muss dieser ort ist
mitten auf einer der meistfrequentierten
handelsrouten der karibik im siebzehnten
jahrhundert das heißt hier war geld und
das muss man immer verteidigen
vor 400 jahren ein juwel der karibik
der einheimische archäologe rhetorik ray
weiß wie die briten ist in spanien einst
abspenstig machen
als die engländer 1655 jamaika eroberten
bauten sie als erstes eine festung im
prinzip war das nur ein lattenzaun mit
dem sie die insel verteidigten
heute ist nur noch dieser halbkreis hier
übrig das war der erste englische bau
auf amerikanischem boden
die festung wird ausgebaut und die stadt
wächst immer weiter
bald ist port royal eine der wichtigsten
städte der welt
als die stadt gebaut wurde war sie
größer als boston und reicher als ganz
london
doch dieses juwel fernab vom königreich
ist nicht einfach zu beschützen
er wendete sie machten etwas sehr
ungewöhnliches sie schickten den
ruchlosen gefährlichsten kriminellen auf
dem planeten eine offene einladung sich
auf der insel niederzulassen piraten
die zweite hälfte des 17ten jahrhunderts
ist die blütezeit der piraterie
rund 5000 freibeuter treiben ihr unwesen
auf see und machen port royal zu ihrer
hauptstadt
waren etwa die piraten in diesen
gebäuden zu hause
es ist kaum zu glauben aber diese
rauflustige piraten arbeiteten an
auftrag der engländer
es klingt verrückt aber es war das
kleinere übel diese gesetzlosen auf
seine seite zu ziehen und die spanische
schiffe an greifen zu lassen dadurch
schützen sie ihren eigenen handel und
schwächten ihre feinde
unter der herrschaft der piraten blüht
port royal auf schon bald hat das
anarchisten lässt mehr als 8000
einwohner
die karibik war der wilde westen des
17ten jahrhunderts und port royal war
quasi dodge city
muss angeblich war jedes vierte gebäude
in port royal eine bar oder ein puff in
aller welt war die stadt als sündenbabel
bekannt
dass spätere schicksal der stadt
offenbart sich unter der
meeresoberfläche
am horizont lauert eine gefahr wer weder
die briten lacht die piraten armee
gewachsen sind
[Musik]
archäologen haben hier in den trüben
gewässern rund um paul
überreste verlassener straßen gefunden
löcher in den jahrhunderte alten mauern
zeigen wohin sie verschwunden sind
hier sieht man drei löcher in der mauer
das größte von ihnen ist hier an der
leim street
war einst eine der wichtigsten straßen
in port royal
[Musik]
doch warum sind teile der stadt im meer
versunken
ein seltsames gebäude das sich immer
weiter zur seite neigt gibt aufschluss
über die besondere biologie von
das gebäude ist mehr als 15 grad im sand
versunken
man nennt es auch das schwindel die
gehaus denn wenn man dort hineingeht
kippt man zur seite
das karibische archipel ist eine
geologisch sehr aktive gegend
jamaika sitzt genau auf der nahtstelle
der karibischen platte und diagonal
micro platte sie treffen sich in einer
sogenannten transform störung diese
verwerfungen reiben aneinander und
können erdbeben erzeugen einige von
ihnen sind sehr flach und können zu
starken verwüstungen auf der
erdoberfläche führen
am 7 juni 1692 kam es zu einem
verheerenden erdbeben mehr als fünf
hektar land versinken augenblickliche
mehr
[Musik]
die schweren bauten hatten plötzlich
keinen festen boden unter den füßen
sondern flüssig sandigen
da wird plötzlich flüssig und
verschluckt das
erdbeben vorbei war wurde der sand
wieder fest und schloss häuser und
menschen ein
innerhalb weniger minuten sterben 2000
menschen
3000 weitere dann später an krankheiten
doch das ist erst der anfang
in kauf dass küsten erdbeben erzeugt
einen tsunami überlieferungen zufolge
zog sich das meer anderthalb kilometer
zurück die es mit gewaltigen wellen an
land und die stadt attackierte
[Musik]
es ist eines der fonds die santen
neben james liegen noch eine ganze reihe
anderer fords unter wasser
das ganze gebiet dort vom hafen war
einst land
letzten brief eines überlebenden heißt
es piraten aus dem haus und sahen wie
die leute ihre arme hoben und um gottes
beistand flehten
die stadt ist nicht mehr
funktionstüchtig es ist aus
viele hielten das für vergeltung für all
die verkommenheit und all die sünden die
gottes zorn jetzt ausgelöscht hat
mehr als vier quadratkilometer land
import neue sind zerstört die piraten
hauptstadt findet nie wieder zu alter
pracht zurück doch dank seiner
strategischen lage wird sie ein
jahrhundert später wieder geboren
nelson einer von englands namhaftesten
offizieren wurde 1779 hierher entsandt
und befehligte mehr als 500 männer
informieren lord nelson tut was er kann
um ein absinken von port royal ins meer
zu verhindern dieses marine krankenhaus
wurde aus vorgefertigten elementen
erbaut die in england erstellt und nach
jamaika verschifft worden
[Musik]
das gebäude selbst ist als flach
gründung gebaut worden
das heißt alle säulen sind miteinander
verbunden es ist als würde das gebäude
schwimmen und daher hat es auch mehr als
17 großen wirbelstürmen standgehalten
1907 kommt es zu einem weiteren erdbeben
[Musik]
ist dieses erdbeben war so etwas wie der
letzte sargnagel
und danach sind die meisten leute aus
der stadt geflohen
die natur hat sich die berüchtigte
pirateninsel zurückgeholt und ihre
ruchlosen geheimnisse mit sich in die
tiefe gezogen
[Musik]
meeres ausgrabungen kosten viel zeit und
geduld es gab bereits erste ausgrabungen
doch weite teile wurden noch gar nicht
erforscht wer weiß was für schätze dort
unten noch begraben liegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
vom erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]